fatima belaïd
la team à bellaïd bonsoir vous êtes donc
l'ex épouse de loïk le floch prigent qui
a été successivement pdg de rhône
poulenc pdg de l et pdg de la sncf
vous jetez plutôt l'époque elle alors
ben dans l' affaire elf l'huile a eu 28
mises en examen six mois de prison
préventive
il ya eu un procès qu'on a appelé le
procès du mcee pas le procès elf à quel
procès d'humains il a été condamné votre
ex-mari à trois ans et demi de prison
ferme et à 2 5 millions de francs
d'amande
bon il ya eu appel et dernièrement quand
il ya eu donc l'appel dans ce procès
dumas votre ex-mari était absent il
avait une pancréatite il était dans une
clinique du liban et le médecin chef de
cette clinique du liban a dit que son
état de santé n'était pas gravissime
quand il était avec vous est ce qu il
avait déjà des problèmes de pancréas
jamais non jamais est-ce qu'il avait
déjà du psoriasis
mais allez détient des biens alors votre
ex-mari je donne des nouvelles va
beaucoup mieux
il a quitté la clinique au liban hasard
gâte le 11 mars
1 voilà il va bien il est pas rentrer en
france
ça c'est un petit peu le problème parce
qu'un expert qui l'attend pour
l'examiner mais il n'est pas rentré
l'expert veut pas aller au liban donc
voilà on était un petit peu embêté est
ce que vous pensez vous qu'il
connaissait bien pour avoir été son
épouse
est ce que vous pensez qu'il est en
fuite non je peux pas vous dire s'il ya
but ou pas je crois pas ça me semble un
peu compliqué dans le contexte parce
qu'il va revenir
j'ai pas j'ai pas de réponse là dessus
parce que j'ai vécu avec lui un certain
nombre d'années sans vraiment le
connaître
ouais alors il vous acquitter de loïc le
floch prigent il ya presque dix ans
du jour au lendemain vraiment
du jour au lendemain on va en parler
alors il était ici loïk le floch prigent
il ya six mois et voilà ce qu'ils
disaient tout ça c'est l'erreur vous
êtes d'accord
1 c'est à dire à simon ex époux c'est
vrai mais vous actuelle non mais
attendez vous de cette période mais je
suis resté neuf mois marié s'est
apprécié ma belle avocat elle l'utilisé
beaucoup la carte de crédit de l phare
est un peu trop 300000 val d'europe
quand même c'est bien le fisc est passé
ne vous inquiétez pas pour le
contribuable que le contribuable soit
très bien mais pas trop mais pour moi il
ya un problème effectivement ceux ci
n'auraient pas dû être alors les 19
millions de francs qu'elle a touché lors
du divorce qui les a payés n'ya pas lors
du divorce
lors du divorce personne n'a pu toucher
pas que ce soit c'est quatre ans après
qu'elle reçoit cette somme une après le
divorce
moi je n'ai plus aucune relation entre
amis sur 24 ans restée ne dévisse un bon
copain gervais et l'appartement à
londres ça c'est première nouvelle c'est
l'appartement alors on sait jamais s'il
appartient la famille ou à biedermann on
n'en sait rien d'accord elle ce serait
bizarre il est vraiment d'appartements
ça vous énerve de voir ça ça m'énerve
oui ça m'attriste surtout pour ça c'est
pathétique c'est surtout c'est plus de
la tristesse que oui ça m'agace aussi
les sur sous fait quoi de le revoir un
petit pincement de coeur ou plus rien du
tout dix ans ont passé
ouais alors tu as vraiment un pincement
au coeur mais voulait déjà là comme ça
les plus charmantes fatima des live ou
publié cette semaine un livre qui
s'appelle au coeur de l'empiré elle une
épouse encombrante chez michel lafon
vous avez choisi tout le monde en parle
pour en parler merci interview vérité
alors votre livre est dédié à votre fils
nile ce qu'est né d'un premier mariage
et que le floch prigent considéré
pendant toute la période où il était
avec vous comme son propre fils alors
par les jours avec votre vie vous aimez
à bordeaux au milieu des années 50
votre mère est allemande et votre père
algérien vers votre mère au début de la
guerre elle s'est engagée dans la croix
rouge delà de la wehrmacht et un jour
elle va témoigner à la police dit j'ai
vu des juifs qui étaient électrifiés sur
des fils de fer barbelés et la police
lui dit que si je continue à dire des
trucs comme ça elle est en prison
donc elle s'enfuit d'allemagne et va à
bordeaux se maria votre mère
là elle rencontre un dénommé ben el hadj
qui est originaire de tizi et à ce
moment là il ya beaucoup d'algériens qui
arrive en france pour reconstruire le
pays à 7 après la guerre alors coup de
foudre totale entre entre vos parents au
mépris de l'exclusion dont était victime
mais évidemment après la guerre avec non
seulement les allemands mais en plus les
algériens alors vous venez 155 vous
grandissez dans une hlm à l'école des
deux victimes de votre différence oui
bien beaucoup de racisme à l'époque
quand un jour je vais doigts pleins de
haine et qu'on essaie de me l'enlever de
force de l'école et que je lui dis que
ça ne part pas et qu'elle m'a giflé dit
cité par an sont pas contents ils n'ont
qu'à retourner chez ben bella oui on
vous traite de choix de sale [ __ ] à
cause de votre mère soit de sale [ __ ] à
cause de voter oui c'est pas très loin
après la deuxième guerre dont soixante
dix ans après la libération ça me donne
des migraines pendant toute votre
scolarité vous avez des migraines à
cause de ça et en plus de ça vous voyez
souvent votre père qui est emmené en
pleine nuit au commissariat et qui le
lendemain matin revient avec le le
visage en sang fut très difficile pour
vous cette époque parce qu'on vous
explique que vos ancêtres les gaulois
apparemment vous y croyez pas trop hein
et fit sienne ont préféré de che guevara
angela davis alors vous aident à fond là
très révolté vous êtes lcr trotskyste
vous êtes lutte ouvrière
et puis un jour déçu par le militantisme
vous accepter un emploi de secrétaire
ça vous plaît pas non c'est pas vraiment
ce que j'avais envie de faire mais
compte tenu de la scolarité que j'avais
eu ce qu'on voit d'ailleurs de plus en
plus souvent aujourd'hui c'était un peu
une voie de garage au parti de chez vous
vous allez en allemagne et là vous
rencontrez un dénommé peter vous
installer tous les deux à avignon lui
bosse dans une imprimerie
vous vous occupez de nils l'enfant que
vous avez avec lui
et alors là me sortez tous les soirs
entre amis à avignon et c'est comme ça
que vous rencontrez un barbu de 36 ans
avec des beaux yeux bleus père noël le
présent voilà alors il ya une idylle
une idylle qui n'est
mais deux ans plus tard quand vous
séparer de votre ami allemand peter lui
vous invite dans un chalet dans le jura
vous faites des grandes balades tous les
ans face au grand amour oui on est amis
avant avant qu'il ne devienne mon amour
il suppose évidemment apprécié ce moment
là vous voyez surtout d'ailleurs au
départ pendant les vacances et puis en
88 en 1988 vous venez vous installer à
paris et on est en juillet 89 êtes en
vacances avec lui à taormina et là vous
devenez bon évidemment amis amants mais
aussi presque vous êtes sa confidente
quoi oui très proche il vous fait part
de ses doutes il vous fait pas de son
enfance de ses problèmes de jeunesse de
ses parents oui c'est quelqu'un d'assez
secret en fait il est très très peu
d'amis qui se confiait très peu et moi
il me parlait ouais donc ces deux je
suis d'autant plus atterré par ce qui se
passe ensuite
alors il souffrait beaucoup d'avoir eu
un père indifférent et au contraire une
mer très possessive
d'ailleurs cette mère vous la rencontrez
un jour évidemment elle est pas très
contente que son fils lui ramène
quelqu'un comme vous un se passe pas
très bien le contact est très froid elle
vous fait manger un plat tu fais
et puis alors si vous dites c'est le
genre de gens comme ça à breton catho
qui passent leur temps à tricoter des
pulls pour les africains mais qui parle
aussi sans arrêt de la suprématie de la
race blanche quoi c'est un peu difficile
à supporter dans tous les cas et puis je
me rends compte qu'elle a une attitude
plutôt méprisante
c'est pas je ne suis pas là même si
qu'elle avait rêvé d'avoir quelques
temps plus tard mitterrand nomme loïc le
floch prigent pdg de elf pour vous elles
surtout les rangs rouge arrive que la
fameuse campagne de un jour dans toute
la france il ya eut remarqué les ronds
rouges arrivent il y avait des ronds
rouges
non c'est parce que j'étais tellement
dans toute la bretagne et marquer le
pétrole arrive c'était total
le plus crade loïk le floch prigent de
vieillissement la pdg de elf qui est la
première entreprise française 7
milliards de francs de bénéfices 76 ni
l'employé là il ya un grand moment c'est
le jour où il va prendre possession de
la tourelle et ils vous emmènent dans ce
qui sera désormais son bureau c'est au
dernier étage vous dominez tout paris
c'est un peu les rois du pétrole on
pourrait dire 8 probablement moi non je
l'accompagnent je crois qu'il avait
envie de faire partager ce moment qui
était importante pour lui et là il vous
confie la création d'une fondation
humanitaire la fondation elle à la fois
pour redorer le blason de la compagnie
et parce qu'aussi les épouses des chefs
d'état africains avec qui elle fait en
contact font tout dans le caritatif dont
il pense que c'est une bonne idée de
vous donner ça oui reste qu'il soit
s'est créé une fondation à vocation
humanitaire afin de redorer le blason de
la compagnie et puis d'apporter une aide
humanitaire dans les pays où s épuisent
le pétrole pour un lire et donc ils me
demandent de m'occuper et
j'accepte alors lui vous pousse
effectivement inventé cette fondation
y'a que alfred sirven qui est dubitatif
oui alfred pense que c'était une bonne
idée
et d'ailleurs on va voir par la suite
que c'est pas vraiment une bonne idée je
suis exposé et qui a des gens dans
l'entourage de loïc qui ne supportaient
pas ces jeux soient à cette place là bas
c'est vrai en même temps que vous
devenez un personnage quasi officiel de
la république le floch prigent vous
emmène partout avec lui dans un falcon
900 que d'un un avion extraordinaire qui
est un avion appartement 1 à 2 donc vous
fait la tournée des maîtres de l'afrique
noire les dîners les réceptions comme
une revanche pour vous quand même sur la
visant c'est pas une revanche c'est un
peu féerique s'arrête c'est long voyage
beaucoup ensemble et je suis en fait ils
souhaitent que je l'accompagné dans tous
ses voyages et c'est plutôt atypique
parce que jusqu'à présent on n'a jamais
vu un président de compagnie a amené sa
femme comme ça
avec lui dans tous ses déplacements et
voyages officiels quoi il veut vous
emmener ce que c'est par exemple parce
que comme vous êtes d'origine algérienne
il revendique le fait que ces
algériennes ça quelque part c'est une
provocation pour lui et puis ça lui
permet aussi des contacts peut-être plus
facile avec les pays du tiers monde où
elle puise son pétrole non c'est
possible mais je pense qu'à l'époque il
était très épris même s'il dit
aujourd'hui que c'était une grave erreur
la pire erreur bien que je pense que ce
soit plus une erreur à mon avis
stratégiques mais pas eu une erreur
amoureuse
je pense qu'il est il avait un grand
plaisir à m'avoir avec lui lvk
mais quand on vous voit en comprendre il
faut alors en 90 vous marier alors le
week end de 9,7 à marrakech la mamounia
ensuite j'ai la new york pour
l'introduction du groupe elf en bourse
c'est l'hôtel pierre kg se sent trahie
par jc quand même une super vie rouge
mais partout moscou l'asie centrale le
qatar ou prenez un appartement de 300
mètres carrés rue octave feuillet à
paris un duplex avec terrasse
c'est venu un jour oui c'est la
pénibilité fantastique mais il ne trouve
pas assez beau l'appartement de la rue
octave feuillet alors il prend un hôtel
particulier rue de la faisanderie 45
millions de francs lui laver notre
projet
il souhaitait acquérir un appartement
quelque chose qui nous appartiennent
on était très bien mais octave feuillet
alors en plus il pourra encore un
deuxième hôtel particulier ça c'est vrai
pour la fondation 1 rue dumont d'urville
voilà voilà
les fusions plus mégalo quand même faut
dire à ce moment là non je pense que
quand on accède à un poste de côte ans
de pouvoir il disait lui même qu'il
avait plus de pouvoir qu'un ministre on
perd un peu la tête
ils se déplacent plus qu'avec un cortège
de voitures gyrophare même pour aller
acheter le pain il se croit invulnérable
à ce moment là oui je crois qu'ils
pensaient général rien un problème c'est
quand il ya un problème il ya un
problème c'est que danielle mitterrand
qui a fait la fondation france libertés
elle prend un peu on brasse de la
fondation elf et vous faites une erreur
elle vous envoie un jour son ami son
grand ami raphaël du web qui vous
propose quelque chose et vous les
conduisait et vous en a voulu danielle
mitterrand samedi oui en fait je ne
prends pas trop vous seriez ce qu'on me
raconte quand on me dit que mal à
mitterrand est agacé qu'elle me raconte
qu'elle
qu'elle pense que je veux absorber la
nation france libertés je ne peux pas
imaginer une seconde qu'elle puisse
croire ce genre de choses je pense que
plus il ya de plus il ya de cela
sociation oui mieux le porte
donc je prends pas vraiment au sérieux
mais quand raphaël dois bien me voir le
budget de l'année et déjà vous plaît
c'est qu'ils me proposent rentre pas du
tout dans le cadre des attributions de
la fondation et j'ai refusé
vous savez que c'est un grand ami de
danielle mitterrand raphaël dweb oui
alors rien d'inné quête organisée rue de
bièvre c'est madame mitterrand elle même
qui vous appelle
en ce lundi neovia roger hanin qui est
in blood rénale en lan dumas là vous
découvrir loïk le floch prigent très
cire pompes avec le président la
république
mais bon c'est pas les seuls tout le
monde a l'air de plaire au président
personne ne s'oppose pas parole pendant
une personne donc moi j'y vais parce que
elle se retirera insiste j'ai pas
vraiment envie d'y aller compte tenu des
relations un peu tendues avec madame
mitterrand je ne comprends pas vraiment
le son invitation et j'accepte parce que
si on va me dis que le président veut
absolument faire ma connaissance alors
au retour loïk le floch prigent vous
prend la mare hier la voiture il est
assez peu nous vous dites dans votre
livre
et puis là des rumeurs commencent à
accourir sur vous on vous accuse de
vouloir balancer ce que vous savez sur
les détournements de fonds au sein de de
l' affaire elf
on vous accuse donc de demander de
l'argent en échange de votre silence on
vous accuse même de faire partie d'un
réseau de call-girls et d'avoir été
recruté par tarallo le grand adversaire
de sirven pour séduire loïk le floch
prigent
alors on raconte beaucoup de bêtises à
cette époque des tas de rumeurs en fait
que loïc et elle ferait de même courir
en en même temps pour justifier en fait
le fait que je vais être répudiée juste
après je dois finalement alors vous
accuse d'être capricieuse ou giggs a été
changé la la moquette de votre bureau
parce que vous
pas la couleur non j'étais allergique
ont fait je suis allergique à beaucoup
de produits la comique et je suis
allergique à la colle donc j'ai supporté
pendant trois jours et puis le quatrième
on a changé on a enlevé la colle et on a
reposé la moquette
alors elles sont là ça a l'air d'aller
mieux vous partez en vacances aux usa
langat et larmes d'hackett code et tout
devrait aller bien et aux moments comme
ça vers la fin des vacances vous trouvez
que loïk le floch prigent est pas très
bien il est dans un profond désarroi
il vous fait des sourires de façade et
puis quand vous approchez de lui qu'il
est au téléphone vite ça va bref tout va
bien moi je chantais qu'on fait ça va
pas non ça va pas il a préparé son
départ et je la prends ensuite quand
l'instruction a démarré d'ailleurs que
il a déjà pris un appartement à deux pas
de la maison d'ailleurs qu'il a ce
moment là j'ai un plan bien précis pour
me quitter il n'en laisse rien paraître
pendant ses vacances aux usa alors au
retour vous partez deux jours à avignon
chez votre copine
irène et quand vous revenez à paris les
affaires de loïk le floch prigent ont
disparu de l'appartement et là je
n'arrivais plus à juin où j'ai essayé de
l'appeler il est pas là et sa secrétaire
me fait savoir que de toute façon il
veut plus me parler qu'elle a reçu des
ordres et je reçois dans la soirée la
visite de maurice bidermann qui me dit
que loïc veut divorcer et qu'il faut que
je démissionne de la fondation très
rapidement je refuse parce que ce que je
veux c'est voir mon mari à l'époque et
avoir une explication je comprends pas
son départ je la raison de sa fuite
je sais pas pourquoi il est parti aussi
brutalement il n'y avait pas de conflit
entre nous il n'y avait pas de problème
je crois qu'on avait on avait sûrement
des problèmes comme tous les couples
mais pas de quoi se séparer sans
allemand on avait été amis pendant
longtemps je pensais bien le connaître
et s'il avait voulu me quitter parce que
il tique les amoureux qu'on ne pouvait
plus vivre avec moi pour des raisons
affectives personnel mais attendait tant
depuis ça s'est toujours très bien et ça
c'est très bien il me dit ça c'est votre
mari ça se passe bien il n'y a pas de
souci et du jour au lendemain et vous
quitte
quand vous revenez l'appartement et
vivre chinois il a vidé sa il a vidé cia
puis ces affaires les affaires de son
fils ont disparu de la chambre il ya
même le lit voilà le lien est un mot
d'explication à ce moment là on vous
accuse d'avoir piqué un million dans les
cars la fondation et le jour voulu
vérifier tous les documents ont disparu
voilà parce que je refuse je refuse on
ne divorçait de démissionner de la
fondation et je je fais savoir à
montvillers man que le lendemain je me
rendrai au bureau
et que j'avais travaillé comme
d'habitude dit mais ça je crois pas que
ce soit une bonne idée parce que
figurez-vous qui semblerait qu'il manque
un million dans la caisse la fondation
et on vous accuse d avoir pris dans le
jeu dit il mais je serai au bureau
demain et je ferai j'aurai une nouvelle
le conseil d'administration en plus
fréquente a pris compte et on verra que
rien n'a disparu
et quand j'arrive le lendemain matin la
fondation 1 on refuse de me laisser
rentrer le garde du corps m'empêcher
j'appelle maurice bidermann jeu finit
par entrer et quand j'arrive dans mon
bureau c'est comme à la maison
le bureau a été vidée j'ai plus aucun
document même plus mes agendas même plus
mon quart des notes personnelles plus
rien non non c'est un vrai cauchemar
voilà c'est un vrai cauchemar a par là
je sens une lettre sur mon bureau de
monsieur match tels qu'ils étaient là
pour vous plus que je vous expliquais
complètement donc qui sait peut-être me
dis que les mémoires de l'ordinateur des
ordinateurs ont été effacés il n'ya plus
les statuts ya plus les comptes ya plus
rien et qui veut qu'on va faire une
enquête de police qui va en référer au
président
de la compagnie alors partir de là elles
vont tout faire pour faire accepter le
divorce un lit de mort
andré guelfi un jour vous convoque au
bar du ritz
dédé la sardine et ils vous montrent des
documents estampillés police nationale
un qui parle du passé de vos parents de
vos problèmes psychiatriques de votre
vie dissolue et même de partouzes voilà
alors ce qu'il ya c'est choquant c'est
que
sur le passé tout est absolument exacts
sur la vie de mes parents tout est réel
c'est ça c'est exact c'est la vérité et
puis quand on arrive au présent je fais
des partout dans mon appartement je
m'occupe de mon fils j'ai un
comportement aussi de quelqu'un de pas
tout à fait normal je suis épuisée
surmenés et finalement ce qu'il me
conseille
ah oui vous conseille de partir dans une
maison de repos que je dois accepter ce
divorce que j'ai pas d'autre choix et
que si je continue sur les positions je
serais probablement donc enfermés et que
l'oit prendre à la gare de mon fils il y
avait police nationale sur ces documents
et police nationale sur les documents
donc c'est ce qui me choque les puisse
alors vous explique que loïk le floch
prigent est prêt à faire enlever
l'enfant à vous donner de l'argent en
suisse
si vous acceptez le divorce on vous
propose 15 millions voilà en attendant
c'est plutôt tranquille par mois de
temps en temps mais vous avez eu les 15
millions pour finir j'ai dit oui alors
vous en vous menace d'accident un aussi
on va vous menacer sinon oui parce qu'à
l'époque en fait je veux raconter
comment le président de la première
compagnie française traite sa femme les
menaces les pressions pour me faire
divorcer enfin en bas de chez moi il y
avait une voiture avec deux types en
permanence qui surveillait mon téléphone
était sur écoute et certains se faisait
un plaisir de me rapporter les
conversations que j'avais eu les
endroits où j'étais allé donc j'avais
menacé un moment donné de parler un
journal et de raconter ce qui m'arrivait
et là on m'a dit d'abord que
tout le monde s'en foutait de mon
histoire est que si personne ne croirait
ce que je pense à l'époque parce que
l'histoire est tellement à voir un
cadavre en tu que je pense
qu'effectivement personne ne va me
croirez contenu aussi que régulièrement
on me dit que je suis pas saine d'esprit
que je suis un peu d'accord vous en
parler at il tonné
quand vous comparez à celui qui était
encore votre mari à l'époque il vous
répond ça nous dépasse
on n'y peut plus rien enfin je veux dire
que il a l'air de finalement d'être sous
influence
oui voilà moi j'ai connaissant le loïc
que je connaissais à l'époque
j'imagine pas un instant qu'il ait pu
partir comme ça de son propre chef
donc je suis moi persuadé qu' on le
pousse à divorcer et la confirmation
entre guillemets parce qu'il y en aura
d'autres après mais la première c'est
que lorsque j'essaie de faire en fait un
geste parce que ce que je souhaite moi
c'est qu'on puisse expliquer c'est quand
même l'homme avec qui je vis avec qui je
me suis mariée que j'aime à l'époque
j'ai envie de comprendre ce qui nous
arrive je lui envoie nous quel sort pour
son anniversaire et à ce moment-là ça
l'a visiblement touché il me téléphone
en fin de journée du bureau pour me dire
que il a été très touché par les fleurs
et puis abandonné la voix se casse et
aux pleurs et parce que je lui dis moi
mais enfin ne laissent pas les autres
régler dans histoire parce qu'on est
jeune et à faire que les intermédiaires
c'est à dire que moi il disparaît et je
ne leur vois pas c'est alfred sirven
trucks qui me dit à un moment donné en
tapant du poing sur la table
vous ne reverrez jamais votre mari s'est
terminée si vous avez un compte à régler
ses achats
moi je lui réponds moi mais c'est avec
vous que j'ai été mariée je veux parler
à mon mari c'est un vrai cauchemar en
fait et à ce moment là lui me dit mais
ça n'est plus je lui dis régler nos
problèmes entre nous s'il te plait bien
par lowe's ans et il le dit mais ça
n'est plus entre mes mains et ça nous
dépasse et je ne peux plus rien faire et
je ne s'appellerait plus ça me fait trop
mal passé dernièrement le sincère que
j'ai dû avoir
finalement vous accepter le divorce
et vous partez en palestine vous partez
à gaza retrouver vos racines arabes pour
vous reconstruire et vous dit à gaza
finalement j'étais moins en danger qu'à
paris et puis voilà et puis ensuite il
ya la mise en examen votre mise en
examen sept la première d'ailleurs dans
la sphère l1 et loïc vous mais à partir
de là toutes les sommes dépensées sur le
dos c'est ce qu'il a fait ici oui c'est
facile de justifier ainsi les ces
débordements financiers plus on met 300
personnes 300 milles ça me parait
drôlement démesuré mais c'est vrai qu'il
m'a accompagné acheter des robes et
compte tenu de la position qu'il avait
et je l'accompagnais dans tous ses
déplacements
j'avais à être habillée c'est marrant
cette république où tout le monde fait
les courses ensemble il ya christine
deviers-joncour qu'accompagner du match
et c'est berluti loïk le floch prigent
qui vous accompagnent cette attention
fatima bellaïd il ya trois solutions la
première c'est qu'effectivement loïk le
floch prigent a appris des choses graves
sur votre passé la deuxième c'est que
vous savez des choses que vous ne riez
pas du savoir et la troisième c'est un
ordre de mitterrand que loïk le floch
prigent n'a fait qu'accepter sans
discuter
quelle est la bonne réponse la troisième
on sait que c'est musée rend absolument
indien le peuple et jean il faut que
vous quittez cette femme absolument
et d'ailleurs beaucoup protagonistes
dans le dossier vient et des
personnalités pas des moindres sont venu
le confirmer
pourquoi hrw a vu pourquoi parce que
j'étais trop présente que c'était la
première fois qu'un center smc était
atypique dans ce milieu c'est la
première fois qu'un président de société
de cette importance en plus amenés son
épouse avec lui dans tous les
déplacements dans les voyages officiels
j'assistais à des signatures de contrat
et je pense que certains avaient peur et
se méfier de ce que j'avais pu entendre
des confidences que loïc aurait pu le
faire
donc j'étais gênante merci
ces jeux